المزيد عن مدينه الفيف
واهميتها في هذا الارض تعتبر الفيف مركزا
ثقافيا وتاريخيا مهما في اوكرانيا وقد
تعرضت المدينه لعده هجمات صاروخيه وجويه
روسيه منذ اندلاع الحرب
تتمتع الفيف بموقع استراتيجي باتجاه الغرب
الاوروبي فهي تبعد 70 كيلومترا فقط عن
الحدود البولنديه اي انها قريبه جدا من
حدود الناتو
تحولت المدينه الى قبله او وجهه اوليه
للنازحين الاوكرانيين منذ اندلاع الحرب
وهي تستضيف اكثر من 200 الف نازح اضافه
لعدد سكانها البالغ 700 الف
ينظر الى الفيف على انها المعبر الابرز
لامدادات الاسلحه الغربيه لاوكرانيا فضلا
عن كونها البوابه الاولى لاستقبال
المسؤولين الاجانب الذين يزورون البلاد
اكثر من ذلك الفيفا انتقلت اليها العديد
من السفارات الاجنبيه من كييف الى جانب
العديد من المؤسسات الاعلاميه لتغطيه
مجريات الحرب